قمه
تونس العربيه عام 2004 التي اجلت لماذا
اجلت اجلت لان هي قمه سميت قمه الاصلاح او
شيء منها القبيل وفي هي القمه التي وقعت
فيها التعديلات ليوم المراه على ميثاق
الجامعه العربيه وفي البيان الختامي كانت
هنالك فقره حتى في التعديلات تخص الحقوق
والحريات
كان كان هناك تباين في المواقف بين الدول
العربيه
ولما لم تبلغ الامور الى اتفاق حول
صياغه النص
تونس كم دوله تتراس القمه مضيفه لها
الدوره الرئاسيه الجديده همم طلب التاجيل
القمه واجلت
يعني لم تكن لا تخرج
بالتوصيات التي تريدها واشنطن
التعديلات تمت عن طريق المجلس الوزراء
الخارجي
[موسيقى]
قمه يعني اتحاديه تعبير لسبب ضغوط غربيه
بموضوع الاصلاح والتغيير هذا القراءه
المعقوله ولكن عمليا
في في العربيه وقمم الافريقيه وغيره يعني
كلام سفيره
لم يكن لديه التحفظ على الاصلاحات لان
الاصلاحات كانت تماس بعد الحقوق منهم حقوق
المراه غيره وليست لم تكن هنالك اشكاليات
ولكن كان يحاول ان يضغط على الدول الاخرى
كي تتمنى بعض
المواقف كانت متباينه على الاقل لا يمكن
يعني حتى تفشل القمه
التنسيق مع بعض الدول العربيه مثلا من قبل
الرئيس الاسبق هو المباشر للتنسيق هو كان
لانه وزير الخارجيه همم
وانقذت القمه وتم التعديل